bonjour messieurs merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france a de la lys boumédiène
quel est l'impact de l'extension du pas
salutaire sur votre activité
oui pour nous c'est avant toute chose
une attitude
et une assignation de l'aviation qui ce
qui se renforce de plus en plus c'est
politiquement inacceptable que
représente la république emmanuel macron
ne soit pas revenu sur cette décision
absolument injuste qui remet en cause la
fonda mentalité de notre des libertés de
la france nous sommes le pays des droits
de l'homme et tous nos voisins sont
choqués donc j'étais en belgique et à
peu près il ya deux semaines et mes amis
belges sont choqués de voir que la
france a opté pour une politique aussi
totalitaires et d'obliger les
concitoyens à se faire vacciner pour
pouvoir faire du sport pour pouvoir se
meut consommée sur une terrasse dans les
restaurants pouvoir voyager c'est
absolument cesser c'est inacceptable
mélangez travailler avec les commerçants
vous travaillez avec grand nombre de
commerçants quelles sont les
conséquences de cette obligation de
présenter pas sanitaire survola sur vos
relations avec eux
ne savait pas plus tard que ce matin
donc il ya beaucoup de situations
conflictuelles donc d'obliger
les commerçants et les clients sur tous
les clients de porter le masque c'est
absolument c'est compliquer thuel et de
plus ça porte atteinte
donc là notre activité les chiffres
d'affaires qui ont dégringolé depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire et qui
continue avec l'obligation si
l'obligation du pass and sister se
confirme sur le marché on nous ce sera
un impact un impact sur nos chiffres
d'affaires sont très limitées et sur le
mieux vivre qu'on avait sur les marchés
donc d'avoir cette tension continuelle
donc avec les agents de sécurité avec
les agents de police avec les
commerçants les clients donc ça sera
intenable donc c'est absolument
inacceptable c'est pour cette raison
nous appelons aujourd'hui pour le 7e
samedi à continuer à nous mobiliser pour
la manifestation contre le passé ni
terre et s'il le faut nous saisirons le
tribunal une strate yves comme l'ont
fait nos collègues sur dans les yvelines
la région parisienne et strasbourg et
qui ont bien hassani terre donc
l'obligation du pass à lithaire qui a
été invalidé par les juges des tribunaux
administratifs donc nous en prendre de
même s'il faut en arriver là nous
n'aurons pas besoin de saisir un
tribunal katif au faire annuler cette
obligation c'est absolument inacceptable
et comme je disais donc ça fait deux ans
qu'on souffre et présenta république et
le gouvernement continue persister dans
le clivage donc le clivage entre les
français bon j'ai vu ce matin des images
sur race où il y avait des centaines de
nos compatriotes dont qui ont créé des
terrasses des terrasses et terrasses de
la liberté et qui en comptent donc on
oppose un peu les citoyens nous sommes
entre nous c'est absolument oui et c'est
absolument inacceptable qu'on l'a vu ce
matin une image choquante les
les terrasses désertées pour les
terrasses de liberté des terrasses des
gens qui sont assis par terre sur le sol
donc c'est absolument c'est l'image
désolante mais
faire réagir françois krakowski vous
vous êtes médecin est ce qu on a une
idée claire de l'effet de l'extension du
planétaire en matière de lutte contre la
propagation de l'épidémie
alors je pense que le raccourci est un
peu un peu fort ce qu'on a vu c'est qu'à
partir de la mise en oeuvre du pass
sanitaire une accélération de la
réalisation des des vaccins on a vu une
courbe qui commençait courbe de nombre
de vaccinations qui commençait à
s'aplatir en début d'été et qui est
reparti à la suite de la mise en place
du pass sanitaires alors ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on a une couverture
vaccinale qui est intéressante avec un
peu plus de 71 % de personnes qui ont
reçu au moins une dose et on arrive
presque à 64 % de personnes qui sont
totalement vacciner et se poser des
chiffres qui sont à mettre au regard des
types de population par âge puisque
quand on a plus de 30 ans on dépasse
quasiment les portes je crois tout les
transits les tranches d'âge pardon mais
80% de vaccins de avec un vaccin de
vaccinés avec un vaccin et on arrive
presque à 70% toutes tranches d'âge au
dessus de 70 70 % donc ça a eu un effet
intéressant maintenant entre l'effet du
pass et de l'épidémie serait je pense
pas que ce serait une erreur de faire
une corrélation directe
maintenant ce qu'on a vu sur cette vague
qui a eu lieu le courant de l'été a
priori encore une fois il faut il faut
mettre il faut faire attention à ce
qu'on prédit et je prédis rien du tout
ce qu'on voit c'est quand une courbe du
nombre de personnes atteintes qui
commence à diminuer mon ce qu'elle va
repartir je ne sais pas suite à la
rentrée pour l'instant elles diminueront
à une courbe du nombre de décès qui est
très basse et on a une tension spital
hier qui reste est tout relatif pendant
cette vague qui étaient majoritairement
dus aux variants delta donc une
politique sanitaire où je suis pas sur
le non je suis pas sur l'idéologie
infléchir une politique sanitaire qui a
été assez efficace donc ensuite que des
avis divergent qui est un débat sur le
fond de l'application d'un pass
sanitaires ou d'une obligation vaccinale
c'est tout à fait normal je trouve ça
très sain et je pense qu'il faut amener
à en discuter de plus en plus sur ce
qu'on appelle la promotion de la santé
c'est à dire comment mieux appréhender
les questions sanitaires par la
population et permettre à chacun d'être
beaucoup plus autonome et responsable
vis à vis de sa santé on voit on a vu
lors de cette crise qui avait beaucoup
de progrès à faire et donc j'espère que
c'est cette promotion de la santé qui
avait des disciplines de la santé
publique sera largement investi dans les
années à venir abdelaziz boumédiène à
partir du 30 août c'est donc mardi
prochain tous les salariés qui
interviennent dans les établissements ou
pas sanitaire est demandé aux usagers
tous les salariés devront donc présenté
le sésame alors employeurs comment se
met en place cette mesure chez les
commerçants
chez les commerçants nous on a une
partie des commerçants qui est qu'elle
va cinéma la grosse majorité qui n'est
pas vaccinée nous avons beaucoup de nos
collègues nos camarades finition pas
vacciner que sont contre le pass annie
terre et qui ont rejoint les cordages
cet après midi donc j'en profite pour
rendre hommage à tous les soignants les
soignants qui ont été là je pense que
président un public l'a oubliée au
gouvernement n'a oublié les soignants
comité d'action jeu un rôle fondamental
dans la crise sanitaire du prêt 1019 et
de les obliger au jour d'aujourd'hui les
faire sortir et dont ils sortent à
nouveau dans la rue on a des milliers de
blouses blanches qui sont attendus dans
les deux manifestations sur la ville de
lyon on trouve quand même servi de table
et on le voit déjà on y voit des
transports c'est l'autre jour sur la
gare de bercy il ya huit personnes qui
ont été exclus qui ont dormi dehors des
personnes âgées à une heure du matin qui
ont été exclues mais a refusé et juste
pour vous dire que juste pour être
est ce que vous sentez qu'il ya eu
effectivement un impact lié à
l'extension du planétaire est ce que
vous avez et côte de salariés chez les
commerçants qui ont
décidé de se faire vacciner pour
faciliter le quotidien
ce qui se passait comme einstein
collègues comme nous mêmes comme moi
même donc tous les trois jours on va
perdre et déteste ce un coût
considérable d'assiette social on aurait
pu l'utiliser contre la maladie du
cancer qui provoque beaucoup plus de
décès que commis le 19 donc nous on
trouve regrettable qu'on puisse nous
obligez qu'on nous oblige
l'immunité collective on l'aura sans
obligation sans obligation s'ancrer tous
clivages s'entraider ça crée des
tensions déjà ce matin sur notre marché
des états-unis à lyon 8e il y avait des
tensions il y avait des tensions avec
les agents de sécurité des agents de
police avec les clients et les
commerçants de tout niveau des clients
on pouvait pas obliger toutes les
personnes qui viennent sur les marchés à
mettre le masque ou à avoir le passe à
lithaire ça ne sera pas possible ça va
faire chuter notre activité ça va faire
chuter nos chiffres d'affaires déjà la
majorité une bonne partie de nos
collègues ont dû déposer le bilan ils
ont failli dans la restauration par les
marchés un peu partout dans cette
activité c'est très difficile la crise n
19 on en a pas on n'a pas besoin que les
politiques d'en rajouter
l'immunité collective françois cabau
grabovski qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
vous répondez
mais si on continue dans cette direction
là où on va bientôt y être les experts
mentionnés un taux de 80% de de
couverture vaccinale pour avoir a priori
priori puisque encore une fois on en
apprend à quasiment chaque jour sur
cette crise sanitaire est cette épidémie
une couverture vaccinale et puisse donc
suffisante pour créer une immunité
collective vers on verra j'ai environ
mais a toujours aux aguets faut être
vigilant non ce que j'entends je suis
bien où je suis tout à fait d'accord
c'est évitons les clivages on a tous un
même objectif je pense qui est celui de
sortir de cette crise est le plus vite
possible pour retrouver notre vie
d'avant arrêter d'avoir à montrer un
pass pour aller prendre chez les
commerçants ou au restaurant ou prendre
le train
voilà donc ensuite il faut pas tout
mélanger non plus je n'ai que des amis
commerçants dans le coin de reims je
peux vous dire que les terrasses elles
sont loin d'être désertés qui plus est
voilà aussi évidemment ils en ont marre
delà de la crise comme tout le monde
mais nous y compris et bien sûr qu'ils
préféraient je discutais avec eux évité
passani terre c'est pas leur job eux ce
qu'ils ont envie c'est de faire de la
restauration du bar etc et 2 et 2 et 2
et de faire plaisir et nous on a juste
envie d'en profiter donc c'est on a
envie d'en arriver là donc c'est juste
ce qu'il faut garder en tête c'est que
ce sont celles à la crise a créé ces
difficultés et on en sortira d'autant
plus vite qu'on arrivera à une
couverture vaccinale en regard des
protections qui nous permettront
d'arrêter le virus c'est le seul
objectif qu'il faut garder en fertile
pour arrêter ça arrêter les maladies
graves et les décès dès qu'on en arrive
là mais bon on pourra retrouver notre
vie d'avant et c'est ce qu'on souhaite
tous et on l'espère évidemment merci
beaucoup françois krakowski médecins
spécialistes de santé publique merci à
vous également abdelaziz mediène
président de l'association des
commerçants indépendants un des marchés
de france